[music playing]
We are here to
document the lives
of people living in Alaska.
The harsh reality is the
environment we're up against,
it makes it tough to do our job.
Get out of there.
Working on life below
zero can be very dangerous.
Gun's here, camera's here.
Never know what to expect.
Hey, hey!
You [bleep] see that?
Gonna be tough, but we're
going to get the shot.
Every scenario, we
got to prepare for this.
But we're still smiling.
We're having fun, still
making like below zero.
Yes!
Bring it on.
[ice cracking]
[music playing]
This is what keeps
me up at night.
We arrived to the
Hailstones' Kiwalik camp
just before dark last night.
Unfortunately, the storm
that we're expecting
could be a little bit
worse than what we thought.
Winds gusting to up
to 65 miles an hour,
which is a hurricane
level windstorm.
And it keeps getting worse.
We actually had to
abandon our camp
and come and take refuge in
the teepee with the Hailstones.
Survived the night and the
crazy winds and woke up.
And we came outside.
And the temperatures
dropped about 40 degrees.
The wind just shifted to the
West, which is really unusual.
And it pushed up the high
tide underneath the ice,
totally flooded this delta where
our snow machines were parked.
Yeah, this is deep, a
couple of feet of slush.
If we don't get them
out really quickly,
they're going to become encased
in new ice, which is just
going to be a disaster for us.
So we're going to get
some help from Chip
and tow these machines
out as quickly as we can.
[motor humming]
This is half the fun.
[chuckles]
Yeah, looks like
it's good to me.
[motor whirring]
There's one.
And that's the worst
part is the basket sled.
You get that frozen
in, and it's horrible.
This is a fun
winter task, tying
knots under water in 10 below.
OK let's do it.
Ready?
[engine revving]
Yep pretty good system
here, takes a lot of manpower.
We got a deep one here,
last one, sitting pretty low.
Let's do it, boys.
[engine revving]
Good job, guys.
That was a close call.
Nothing's going to stop us.
We're undaunted.
Yeah, we'll get through it--
Yep.
--storms, floods, whatever.
Bring it on.
It's not going
to stop television.
In five years on
"Life Below Zero,"
this has been one of the
craziest 24 hours for me,
for sure.
Now we need to go back to
our camp and assess damage.
And who knows what we're
going to find there.
We need to rebuild our shelters
and assess our gear situation
and make sure that everybody
can stay warm and safe.
It's a matter of life and death
in the Arctic in the winter,
having good shelter.
There's no one we
can call out here.
There's nowhere we can go.
We're out on the coastal
plain of the Arctic Ocean.
We need to be
totally self-reliant.
This is about as
extreme as it gets.
We made it back to camp.
It's become part of the ocean.
[wind rustling]
Whoa, there's a tremendous
amount of water underneath.
The floor of the tent is
like a waterbed right now.
It's kind of surreal
to be in 10 below zero
in the middle of winter in the
Arctic and have water issues.
We prepare for snow
and ice and wind.
But you don't expect
your tent to flood
in the middle of winter.
It's really kind of surreal.
Lesson learned, I guess.
It takes such an effort to get
out here that once we do make
it out here, we
really want to make
it work, because the logistics
are just so daunting.
And this place is incredible.
It's really brutal,
beautiful, and wild,
and makes for really
wonderful television.
It's going to take some more
work on the part of the crew.
But I think we can do it
and keep it functioning
and get back to filming
till the next storm.
We're celebrating Ben's birthday
today, probably not the way
that he expected.
But we're having fun and
making the most of it.
Food, food, food, food, yay!
[laughs] Let's eat
it while it's hot.
Yeah.
So I feel very grateful
and fortunate right now.
I'm getting a very memorable
and unique birthday experience,
my birthday caribou.
Yum.
It's an arctic gourmet.
It's awesome.
It's a great birthday dinner
for me and for the whole crew.
It's a little hot, Kevin.
Thank you.
[wind blowing]